der wald will gar nicht mehr aufhören
wir sind unterwegs im osten von polen an
der grenze zu belarus die polen haben
eine so genannte sicherheitszone
eingerichtet was genau hier passiert es
passiert unter ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit
auch für uns ist an einem der vielen
checkpoints schluss journalisten können
nicht berichten weil polen nicht will
dass die bilder von hier um die welt
gehen
deshalb haben wir uns mit anna und ihren
freunden verabredet aktivisten die in
den wäldern unterwegs sind um menschen
zu helfen ihre kamera haben sie immer
dabei wenn sie mit wasser nahrung und
rettungsdecken losziehen
diese leute hatten glück dass wir sie
gefunden haben dass wir zu ihnen
gelangen konnten aber was sollen wir
dann tun wir wissen wenn wir die polizei
rufen damit sie um asyl bitten können
dann wird das nicht geschehen das wird
einfach nicht passieren das ist keine
option ja das bringt mein herz dieser
moment wenn wir die leute im wald
zurücklassen müssen wenn moral und
gesetz einfach so weit auseinander licht
ausnahmezustand seit september schon für
anna und die anderen ist das eines eu
staates unwürdig
interventionen erzählen sie uns nennen
sie ihre einsätze in den wäldern entlang
der polnisch weißrussischen grenze oft
hören sie geschichten von gewalt davon
dass hunde auf geflüchtete gehetzt
werden auch von polnischen
sicherheitskräften
für mich ist das das schlimmste ihnen zu
sagen in welcher schwierigen situation
sie sind viele von ihnen wurden
getäuscht
sie wussten nicht wo sie genau landen
sie sind nach belarus gekommen und dann
wurden sie irgendwo an diese 400
kilometer lange grenze gebracht
dann werden sie von denen belarussen
rüber geschickt sie schneiden ein loch
in den zaun helfen ihnen rüber und dann
sind sie auf der anderen seite in polen
menschen auf der flucht als druckmittel
es ist ein zynisches ein perfides
schauspiel was das regime lukaschenko
gerade auf führt damit europa die
sanktionen gegen belarus lockert hybride
kriegsführung ist das holen hat deswegen
seine truppen verstärkt 12.000 soldaten
grenztruppen polizisten aus dem ganzen
land sollen für sicherheit sorgen wenn
der zone zu der polen selbst
hilfsorganisationen den zutritt verwehrt
[Musik]
alina mischok arbeitet für das rote
kreuz ihre eltern leben in der
sicherheitszone deshalb darf sie rein
weiß was dort passiert
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll ich
weinen oder was es ist schrecklich wenn
die welt sehen würde was da passiert
wäre die reaktion an das gleis stand
deswegen werden journalisten nicht
reingelassen keine ngo es keinen
humanitären organisationen ich sag mal
so wenn es eine safari gibt und mit dem
hubschrauber löwen gejagt werden empört
sich die welt und wenn es jagd auf
menschen gibt ich habe keine angst das
zu sagen bitte senden sie das dann
empört sich niemand weil es niemand
sieht weil niemand da reingehen kann
nicht
in hannover erzählen uns die aktivisten
wird eine kurdin aus syrien behandelt
ihr bein ist gebrochen ihr sohn ist aus
österreich gekommen durfte für 15
minuten bei ihr sein sein gesicht will
er nicht zeigen zu gefährlich glaubt er
[Musik]
plötzlich wird es hektisch auf der
anderen seite ist ein krankenwagen der
armee vor gefahren drei frauen heißt es
werden zurück in die sicherheitszone
gebracht die smile ist verzweifelt weiß
nicht ob seine mutter dabei ist
vielleicht ist sie noch im krankenhaus
ihr habt sie antwortet nicht vielleicht
kann sie nicht was kann sie nicht
vielleicht kann sie nicht reden
forst
es wird stunden dauern bis israel und
die aktivistin magdalena gewissheit
haben die mutter wurde zurückgeschickt
in die sicherheitszone
das ist schade denn das ist eine
tragödie ein verbrechen das ist ein
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
menschen werden die dinge behandelt
nicht mal wie tiere sondern wie dinge
die meisten leute wenn die uns sehen die
halten uns ganz fest halten uns für fünf
minuten weinen und sagen danke ihr seht
uns als menschen
die fotos und videos die makler und
zeigt sind aus dem niemandsland diesmals
eltern waren dort 22 tage lang von den
polen mehrfach völkerrechtswidrig über
die grenze geschickt vor speck nennt man
das die belarussen aber lassen niemanden
wieder rein ins land es gibt tote
niemand weiß wie viele und verzweifelte
menschen ohne winter kleidung ohne
schuhe bei temperaturen die nachts unter
den gefrierpunkt fallen
auch anna kennt diese videos und sie
weiß das sind keine einzelfälle
die zahl derer die sich in der
grenzregion aufhalten ist groß
allein letzte woche haben unsere teams
auf der polnischen seite mehr als 1500
menschen geholfen wir führen darüber
eine statistik wir haben namen
nationalität alter
wir wissen dass uns 1500 verschiedene
menschen allein in einer woche die es
geschafft haben in
einer woche die die polnische grenze
überquert haben
das ist das minimum an leuten die da
sind wir können unsere schätzung nur
darauf berufen weil man den offiziellen
statistiken der polnischen oder
russischen behörden überhaupt nicht
trauen kann you can aus meiner sicht
sind da gerade rund 10.000 menschen
menschen die sich im wald verstecken
spielball mächtiger interessen ihrem
schicksal überlassen an europas
außengrenzen
[Musik]